[Musique]
ce grand prix de bordeaux pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent pour ce deuxième match
de ce grand prix pour ce vendredi
pour les courageux qui ont pu encore
nous rejoindre ce soir il ya les deux
matches venette de ce prix qui auront
lieu
wenger tient la tête 2 0
[Musique]
en attendant
avant de parler des joueurs je vais voir
le président peut en avoir si vous avez
donc
et aujourd'hui est bien c'est de vouloir
régler propre l'autre 40 ans
[Musique]
calé sur la bonne fréquence vous à metz
ou si vous allez à l'accueil
donc on vous le temps qu'on vous le
règle voilà donc ça c'est très important
ensuite évidemment ce qui est important
aussi c'est l'écran géant qui vous
permet de suivre la partie sinon ça
n'aurait aucun intérêt donc vous allez
pouvoir c'est libre suis donc la partie
entre les deux joueurs
en même temps vous découvre fait pour
maintenir au pouvoir
[Musique]
ces rendez vous
le jeu des chaises ou alors ce match où
le deuxième quart de finale
[Musique]
bonne fête à cannes
le pam
dans l'égalité deux parties semi-rapides
mêlant joueurs il ya des pépites de
départage des beats se sont départis de
cinq minutes uniquement en cas d'égalité
évidemment donc les deux joueurs vont
s'affronter maintenant son refus de 10
sont prêts particuliers le premier
d'entre eux est bien il est champion
d'aquitaine 2006 alors il remplace le
champion pris en 2007 qui était franc
parler
ap
[Musique]
où
je me
je suis dans la finance et bien je vous
demande d'applaudir d'autres opérateurs
qui veulent pas
monde aujourd'hui
sectionnelles pour lui
ça va être intéressant de voir
va se passer
demande d'applaudir le champion
d'aquitaine 2006 marc lui avait été
marqué avec un policier le bonjour marc
alors préparé pour ce grand match
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
merci aux couleurs choisies encore pour
l'encourager
ça va pas être facile évidemment trouver
face à lui l'un des meilleurs blues
nous
ces champions du monde de schengen
en m c'est donc ses portes hier soir
dans notre lady champion de france huit
vice champion d'europe de brit donc deux
fois vainqueur aussi de l'équipe de
russie avec l'équipe de france et c'est
lui qui a marqué le point chaque fois je
vous demande d'applaudir un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde actuellement
le grand maître international laurent
frayssinet laurent frayssinet bonjour
laurent alors aussi c'est le sixième
rang bordeaux aujourd'hui réparation
spéciale
bon
[Musique]
d'aucuns pour ce match
les gros travaux
après les séances suivantes nous allons
maintenant accueillir la remise à niveau
i roll national patrick besse va pas
arriver à ses fins il applaudir je vous
laisse avec lui merci stéphane je vous
rappelle que nous allons assister un
match en deux parties 20 minutes par
joueur
nous allons effectuer le tirage au sort
pour savoir qui va jouer avec les blancs
et les noirs on alternera les couleurs
en cas d'égalité nous aurons deux bis de
départage un cas de nouvelles qualités
1,8 en cinq minutes pour les blancs
[Musique]
je suis pressé les jours avec les blancs
première balle
à me fait pas perdre
voilà c'est parti donc voilà c'est parti
nous avons récupéré la partie voilà avec
8 défense sicilienne des noirs défensif
chilienne
on va rappeler c'est le caractériser par
ce coup ici secousses et 5 mois et sur
l'ouverture ou 4 voilà
et avec une variante ans est une
variante fermé avec ses 3 qui était un
coup joué par un russe au début du 20e
siècle qui s'appelait à la pile donc la
variante à la pine de la défense
sicilienne
mais les noirs ont choisi de jouer un
centre retenu avec donc et si c'est
aussi ce petit roquet a dit jouez pas
lorsqu'il est donc le rock c'est une
fois dans la partie
le roi est venue de deux cases ici sur
la droite et la tour est venu vers le
centre on va pouvoir après a ramené la
tour au centre afin de faire jouer cette
tour face au camp ennemi
donc pour l'instant c'est une position
donc on voit que les joueurs d'un jour
jovite un même marque l'uec est quand
même un bon joueur donc il connaît bien
ses ouvertures
même si évidemment il doit les games -
les connaître que que laurent frayssinet
mais quand même c'est un très bon joueur
qui va pas faire d'erreur dirait
gravissime
oui donc là le joueur blanc veut jouer
des quatre avancer sans deuxième pion au
centre est donc assurée info recentre
donc important aux échecs on le rappeler
encore on reparlera l'ont compris c'est
évident c'est le centre de tenir les
positions du centre les noirs ont choisi
lors d'attaqués et noir ont aussi poussé
un pion au centre pour stabiliser la
position au sein très contesté là la
pression blanche au centre donc la a6 a
été jouée par markus keller de bien
connaître son affaire oui il s'est
organisé pour pour faire une attaque de
chaîne voilà il est son expansion sur
l'ale dames et il attaque la chaîne de
pion central blanche et il attaque en
particulier le plan des quatre en
faisant pression sur lui
alors ici on va montrer le pion c5 le
câble et si si si qui font pression sur
tourner quatre qui pour l'instant est
bien défendue par ses 3es par le
cavalier 3 2 attaquants de défenseurs
donc pas de problème les noirs préfère
garder la pression ici comme ça il se
ménage la possibilité pourquoi pas de
jouer 6 4 6
si c'est possible et ils peuvent aussi
augmenter la pression en jouant dame de
6 voilà par contre les blancs ont avancé
le pion à 1,5 alors ce pion est toujours
très importante pour les joueurs d'
attaque parce que ils contrôlent à la
case m6 et puis va permettre certaines
fois des combinaisons alors on dit
souvent que les attaques y diriger vers
le pion le plus avancé
donc là le pion 5 vise la case f6 donc
du côté roy donc signé noir voulaient
faire petit rôle pour mettre le roi de
ce côté là ça serait sans doute le signe
pour les blancs d'une attaque sur les
droits donc peut-être que les noirs vont
choisir peut-être pourquoi pas de faire
le rock
du côté dames de l'autre côté quand le
four à bouger et premier la tour au
centre c'est pas exclue pour l'instant
les noirs attendent préfère attendre de
voir ce que veulent faire les blancs
avant de prendre des décisions très de
connaître son affaire marc cluzel qui
prend son temps
voilà le rock aux échecs et un coup très
intéressant parce qu'il permet d'abriter
le roi est de faire jouer la tour vers
le centre où les colonnes en général
vont s'ouvrir favorablement pour les
tours mais il a un défaut le rock
toujours c'est qu'il donne l'adresse du
roi et donc
une fois quand ses goûts son ennemi
habitent c'est plus facile d'aller le
déloger cavaliers g3
alors qu'on voit signalé juste à
julienne autres opérateurs de vérifier
que nous sommes bien en face sur
l'échiquier géant avant de démarrer la
partie
peut-être pour la revanche tout à
l'heure et pas uniquement sur le sur le
serveur voilà c'est un petit détail
c'est donc le noir laisse planer le
doute sur l'adresse de sang froid
il n'a pas encore roque et voilà alors
le numéro à noter que le numéro des
coups ici sur le côté ne correspondent
pas ou si normalement je vois le blanc
ici le coup de main ici c'est un bug du
logiciel mais qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas important donc il vient de se
décider pour la prise au centre il faut
voir que vous dessinez avait surprotéger
la case des 4 alors oui on peut noter la
surprotection le pion c3 le fou et 3
le cavaliere 3 la dame d un donc ça se
rappelle surprotéger puisqu'il ya
beaucoup plus de défenseurs que
d'attaquants puisque deux attaquants
lecavalier c6 et la dame b 6 donc il
faut récupérer ce point
le problème c'est que si on récupère
avec une pièce ça ne peut être que avec
le fou
essayez la logique c'est de reprendre
avec le pion évidemment puisque si on
avait pris à lecavalier c'était le pire
c'est qu'ils étaient prenables
voilà derniers coups joués par les
blancs ici le pion c21 repris en c3
tranquillement donc laurent frayssinet
la pression et le mans il a tout à
perdre sur ce match et un renault oui il
est archi favori
on va rappeler le classement de la
rentrée ciné 2542 quelques le cinquième
50e joueur mondial et le 2e ou 3e
français 4e prends ta prière français
maintenant puisque quatre chefs et oui
qui s'est fait naturaliser qui est
devenu français l'an dernier quelques
points et d'ailleurs grand chose qui est
chef avait gagné son match le départage
pour le titre champion de france contre
laurent frayssinet exactement au
champion de france l'an dernier ce qui
s'est joué à très peu de choses on peut
signer que ça se raconte un des grands
favoris du championnat de france de
cette année qui est maintenant un des
plus grands championnats du monde
faut lire oui c'est le niveau est
exceptionnel jouets lautier 20e mondiale
maxime vachier lagrave qui est
maintenant votre quatrième avec ses 16
ans ses 16 ans vraiment des gros gros
joueurs toujours christian bauer
évidemment et tous les joueurs qui ont
fait une forte équipe puisque un terrain
équipe de france et oscille entre la 4e
et la 6e place mondiale
oui les joueurs apprenant les échecs de
plus en plus tôt dans les écoles dans la
france entière depuis vingt ou trente
ans qu'il fait que cavalia 5 des joueurs
de qualité sont apparues alors cavalli à
saint malo notamment oui à bordeaux avec
chic et bordelais voilà un petit peu
voilà tu présides l'échiquier bordelais
week-end et club actif à la fois en
gironde et à bordeaux
voilà donne des cours dans les écoles
avec notamment des demandes des jeunes
qui vont venir ce soir
oui on a une vingtaine de jeunes des
écoles qui veut revenir assister aux
différents matchs donc ici laurent vient
de jouer b3 qui étonne coûts qui vise à
interdire la case c4 aux cavaliers donc
ce cavalier à 5 n'aura rien de mieux à
faire que de repartir un jour il veut
repartir évidemment le problème par
contre dupiot du coupé 3 mai donc c'est
que ça affaiblit cette case donc il
préfère repartir tout de suite par
exemple et noir pourrait décider plus
tard de jouer le coupé 4 et contrôler
cette case et pourquoi pas après faire
une manoeuvre cavalia cette cavale et
des 5 et ensuite pointé le cahier en c3
une position qu'il rappellerait le match
précédent
oui il ya eu ce genre de position qui
est apparu alors cavalli h cinglant
fasciné lui aussi qui maintenant à la
menace
direct aux cavaliers prendre g7 ici avec
un échec donc un problème pour les noirs
soit en affaiblir les droits
alors soit en jouant g6 alors j'ignore
pourquoi ça se voit oui ce serait un
affaiblissement parce que tout pion qui
avance les affaiblit affaiblir et sept
cases par ex de 15 voilà général cette
cassure est faible oui et susciter la
case h6 aussi il affaiblit la case ou
même si c'est là qu'ils agissent en
avant ce plan j'ai déjà sous le feu du
fonds ou trois si on bouge ici
évidemment on ne protège plus les cases
et cissé l'exercice alors bien sûr on
chasse le cavalier on a peut-être le
cavalier mais la force d'une pièce par
rapport à un pion
c'est que la pièce peut revenir se
recycler aller sur l'échiquier alors que
le pion ne recule jamais voilà donc on
voit marques ul qui fait pour l'instant
de très bonne partie il a l'air d'être
dans son élément au lion qui les y voilà
il n'y n'affaiblit pas sa position mais
qui joue un coup de dé veloppement a
contrario et ramène le fou sur la place
des fuites
enfin souvent on n'a pas très bonne
presse pas très envie de jouer ce genre
de coups parce que là ça en faire le
tour
on est revenu à la maison c'est moins
grave quand la tour est sorti à la
limite à huy où il était venu là
peut-être donc il a dit il a choisi de
parrot qui c'est un coût plutôt passive
mais monsieur exit sylla verhoek est
tout simplement le simple dames b3 ici
menaces et mat
c'était peut être embêtant il n'a pas
voulu
donc qu'est ce qu'il va faire de son roi
est ce qu'il va laisser s'en remet au
centre étant donné que le centre est et
bien bloqués au maroc les deux
ici on voit que ses pions ici sur les
lieux centraux elles peuvent plus
avancer
donc ils ne peuvent pas on peut pas
ouvrir ce centre ainsi ces plans n'était
pas avancer si le pion était encore en
e2 par exemple on aurait ouvert avec eux
quatre et on aurait pu prendre ici
libérant la puissance de la tour sur le
roi mais assez bloqués voilà les blancs
ce qu'on appelle centre bloqué à l'aller
blanc s'ils veulent ouvrir ce centre il
va jouer à 4 f5 attendant montrer
tournoi il faut tu vas trouver
tu vas trop vite on va on va montrer
effectivement une possibilité pour
casser cette structure ici bloqué c'est
d'essayer de la percée de côté il pourra
percer deux côtés on le fait en général
avec des pions donc on joue f4 on joue
f5 ici pour casser ie6 heraoua la base
de la petite chaîne fera la cercla base
passe de ici la base cfc qui protège
être aussi c'est qu'ils protègent des
scènes qu'elle a pas là bas je passerai
en os 6 et après la trilogie regardant
ce qui se passe sur la dame l'a fait
signer à jouer très vite à 4 pour
essayer d'ouvrir des lignes voilà c'est
quoi du côté de de l'habitant noir voilà
il faut vider le roi ici est tout de
suite bien hivernal refuse toute
ouverture de ligne du côté de son roi et
il pousse bloc le pion en b 4 bien sûr
alors notez quand même qu'il ya cette
colo il ya la colonne c'est avec une
tour mais probablement que les noirs
vont jouer tout retard le cours avait
huit tout simplement petit coup droit
qui va arriver celui-là vite très
désagréable entre le tour la tour et le
roi puisque des clous mais le cavalier
est louée et ça peut immobiliser des
pièces le problème de cette position
c'est que sans doute les blancs seront
les premiers à profiter de la colonne
c'est par le fait que les noirs en leurs
deux tours qui ne sont pas encore lié à
le sens gêné par le sort gêné par le
dans le four est fluide
voilà la colonne c'est donc à vous
repérer c'est comme la bataille navale
évidemment les échecs comme à colombes
et colonne c d e f g ici on appelle ça
comment heureux nous parlons ici en
latéral travers ses travers en trois la
première traverse jusqu'à la 8ème ici
donc c'est comme la bataille navale en
fait un moyen on emploie aussi le mot
ranger mais le terme injuste c'est le
terme de traverse
voilà donc les colonnes et on dit ranger
aussi et les traversées en général on
dit que donc en général comme les pions
en général en combres l'échiquier dès
que les guignols en est ouverte alors
s'avère que les pions ont disparu c'est
sarine savoie l'avons rappelé saha les
pions et disparus une science sur la
colonne est donc ici la tour contrôle
très bien la colonne ouverte ici voilà
donc et peut-être les noirs peuvent
jouer un plan à base de roye b 8 et
mettre eux mêmes une course qu'on
appelle contester la colonne est
conseillé de contester la valeur d'un
c'est donc les les blés blanc que
voudrait dominer cette colonne assez
pour l'envahir pour introduire dans la
position adverse
par exemple le web ont imaginé et
renault des plans à base d'oeufs par
exemple koubéens oui oui on joue autour
d'eux et ensuite on double les tours ici
boum boum pour essayer de voir si on
peut faire pression terrible
plusieurs façons de doubler les tours
alors évidemment ça se calcule tout ça
parce qu'il faut penser que si on met
une touriste ici le fou ici on bouche le
fou de notre côté aussi alors voilà et
alors que tout ça doit être bien pensé
voilà donc qui jouait en d3 laurent
frayssinet voyez la classe des trois
c'est à dire qu'ils seront 6 et en cas
de doublement le fou est libre oui et la
classe des quatre et en sd quatrième
très bien protégé par le fouet le
cavalier il rend son fou le case blanche
actifs oui c'est l'artt il et puis ça
parce que la dame était interceptée oui
et il libère donc cette colonne et c'est
pour s'apprêter à rentrer sur la colonne
c'est pour ces deux tours de et tour
seydoux et des fois mais mon truc et on
peut aussi triplé le fameux lampe pas le
fable triplement d'aller keynes était le
champion du monde avec keane qui est
assez difficile parce qu'une fois que la
ville de tours sont là il faut remettre
la dame mais en sait moins de 1,1 c zéro
ici là sur cette case ici qui n'existe
pas si on pouvait mettre la dame
derrière on a eu un deux trois pièces
mais là on peut pas parce que on voit
bien que par exemple la casse et 3 pour
tripler elle est prise portions b4 et la
casse et 4 aussi par le pion des cinq
donc triplé ce rappeur de sambi le fait
c'est mon salon en frites on a vu que
dell de laurent
deux marques de marque qui veut
contester la colonne s'est donc il
évacue la colonne c'est les mettre à la
msa tour pour contester cette batterie
qui arrive voyez comme c'est logique on
arrivait à trouver les messins petit
problème c'est que ce x fuite ne peut
pas partir sans donner le pion g7
oui voilà donc les tours ne peuvent pas
se lier à cause du cavaliere alors que
les tours blanches se lient les tours
blanches vont se lier et donné que marc
se dit que finalement bon similé tous
ici si sa tour est ici il va échanger
une paire de tourka veille à 5 qui
échangent peur de tout et finalement la
tour seul sans cesse des seuils joue
cavalier à 5
voilà sera pas très avec l'idée de faire
pression sur sur b3 cela il fait
pression aussi bien sûr à oui biensur
bien vu mais mais ces deux cavale et
promettront vers les prend b3 bon
peut-être encore on peut donner ce plan
b pour un pur pour ouvrir là alors
qu'elle peut être l'idée de souffle
bizarre on nous tour d2 quelle est
l'idée de qu'est ce que c'est que ce
coup de tours d2 c'est qu'il veut
peut-être renforcer la défense de d4 et
il va utiliser s'en fout la défense de
ce pion oui ils voudraient resituer sont
fous en voilà un banc f1 il veut
peut-être recyclé s'en fout en f1 est
bizarre on est peut-être celle qu'est ce
qu'il veut faire
peut-être passé la dame ici met la dame
là oui oui mais attention le pion
mettront attaqué le pion métro est
attaquée oui mais pour que la dame est
immobilisé pour l'instant très bizarre
le coutour des deux là de laurent
fasciné que j'ai du mal à comprendre que
peut-il faire
j'ai vraiment du mal à comprendre ce
couteau en d2 c'est un pseudo coude
attente on a l'impression de laurent
frayssinet tour d2 ça c'est un coût de
l'ordre typiquement un coup de grands
maîtres que je ne sais pas décrypté tour
s'est vite voit la marque une pose pas
de questions il va et laisse délester la
position d'une tour l'arrivée il veut
éliminer une tour jusqu'à son ca tour
des huit n'était pas active elle tapait
sur un sur son propre opinion donc là
s'il arrive voilà signer le fait donc il
reprend dufour à fond là bien sûr son se
fout il est un peu mort se fout
d'ailleurs puisqu'il table sur ses
propres pions ses pions sont sourds
blanc et le foot en deux cases blanches
c'est ce qu'on appelle un fondement la
poule c de donc libère il libère la dame
200 rôles de défensif une bonne dame aux
échecs est une dame qui ne défend pas
chaque fois qu'on a une dame libre elle
peut être utilisée pour l'attack puisque
c'est la meilleure pièce d'attac la dame
donc là il a libéré sa dame et il a
défendu la base de sa chaîne qui était
qui était sous pression le pion mais
trois cavaliers h2 alors il va alors il
veut jouer car il va jouer f4 à houlle
alors le coup responsables se disent ils
se décident pour g6 angers 6 pourquoi
parce que marc veut sans doute revenir
en cette les ensuite il veut libérer
cela il veut libérer sato rage va
vouloir échanger sans doute ou bien sûr
c'est évident alors là laurent
frayssinet n'a pas trop le choix
maintenant et son cavalier donc il faut
bouger le cavalier l'on soit 8,6 y
réfléchir et 6 sans doute
soit sans doute g3 qui paraît pas
terrible
c'est f4 qui paraît pas non plus génial
puisqu'on n'y a peut-être envie de jouer
f4 pour jouer ensuite g4 et g5 et se
payer une ce qu'on appelle une rupture
les blancs ont essayé de casser un peu
le il mourir lacaune f
il est de cavalli apsys ce serait
d'obtenir la case 5 pour le cavalier h2
qui rêvent 3 et 1 5 et donc mais c'est
faux vin pur doublé et ça laisserait un
centre de pions supérieur au noir c'est
pour ça qu'il n'a pas joué cavalier m6
et puis ça on sent bien le championnat
aquitaine pour l'instant au nom louis
s'en sort il s'en sort bien
la position est équilibrée franchi cette
foule g7 alors malheureusement ce coup
on pouvait difficilement sa part s en
passer s'il ne voulait pas perdre le
pian et justice pour pouvoir faire jouer
la tour alors la suite c'est de garder
le contrôle sur le pion à s'y attaquer
parce que si on avait joué il faut 7 on
n'aurait pas pu jouer tour ses huit voix
la cause de la perte du pion alors que
là on peut alors l'idée aussi peut-être
renault c'est que les noirs ont aussi
une rupture possible plus tard c'est de
jouer le coup et 6 oui les noirs plus
tard pour la finale pourrait jouer avec
6,6 il arrive à défendre vers laurent
facile mais les noirs devant leurs
responsabilités puisque la menace et
d'un prend effet voilà c'est le sait la
faiblesse alors à noter un autre du
carnet noir
et si ça marche pas m6 a validé surtout
réussi c'est évident je comprends du fou
le fou étant protégé par le cavalier
mais mais le pion g6 saurait emprise du
fou mais si ça marche puisque le pion b3
l'huisserie emprise aussi compliquer
leur attention la marque le mec va sans
doute réfléchir profondément cette
situation
oui donc il faut quand même défendre le
pion à aider ce moment là tout
simplement des formes le pion au fcs et
l autre option tout simplement mettre la
tour en défense alors ça y est
freyssinet réalise ce que réalise le
joueur le plus fort c'est à dire qu'il
est le premier matin qu y est vraiment
quelque part ouais il appuie see donc
créer une pression sur ça pour appuyer
l'appui l'insu rage si sa menace aller
simple ou prend h6 ou cavaliers prend
ainsi ce dernier pion tout simplement et
les noirs n'ont pas le choix il va
falloir jouer le coup h5 qui qui doit
pas l'air mauvais n'ayant ne voit pas de
problème sur 11,5 et que font les blancs
le problème de h5 sais que ça va
permettre aux foules noir the des cases
blanches d exprimer c'est pour ça que le
sexe est pour ça qu on comprend mieux le
lay le fait alors maintenant prouve à
yvan le 6 alors est ce que c'est bien ce
que c'est pas bien ça ça cache un peu la
faiblesse j'ai l'impression par exemple
sur sur vous prend bon si on prend et
forcé puisque le cavalier 17 contrôle et
ça libère la tour on va pouvoir jouer
tour c'est 8
mais c'est vrai que le plus réussi c'est
fort parce qu'il suffit d'éliminer le
kfc est ensuite pour avoir le pian f7
restera de toute façon une faiblesse
c'est la base de la chaîne la base de
l'escalier des pieds en noir fonctionner
l'invasion spatiale que fait laurent
fascinés l'un finalement tranquillement
un petit pas laurent frayssinet est en
train de rendre les pièces de laisser
les pièces c'est noir passive exclu non
choix l'arize pied en france et il a
fait une concession il a donné la paire
de fou il a donné la paire de fou mais
tant qu'il a le bélier d4 d5 c'est à
dire les deux millions fixé au centre
parlons maintenant de l'autre côté voilà
cette faiblesse de ses fans ce pion m6
c'est une faiblesse qui ont fort qui
protégé par la dame mais bon la dame
pour l'instant doit le protéger parce
qu'il souffre le cavalier mais surtout
sa cache ce qu'on appelle cacher la
faiblesse est 7 et donc ça permet à la
tour de vivre ici on sait 8
voilà un peu plus de perspectives quand
il fuit tout l'été purement défensives
oui elle est là aussi la case ces
trois-là sept tours pour taper une fois
de plus sur b3 alors que noter au niveau
du temps dix minutes
il reste dix minutes laurent frayssinet
contre 7 minutes 30 à marquer avec jean
bart en aquitaine 2006 sans doute
laurent va jouer cavalier e 2 pour
mission alors d'un échec 1 donc il joue
dame échec d'un michel dijoux dame échec
faudrait quand même qu'ils se
préoccupent de l'invasion pour ces trois
jours mais charlie 10 et simplement
d'éloigner le roi voilà il le fait on a
sept
je pense qu'il faut qu'ils jouent là il
est il a joué 25 pour pour contrôler une
fois de plus la case lorsque cinq ce que
voudrait faire les blancs sans doute
chronos et mettre leurs cavaliers ont
juste attaqué parce qu'il voulait les
mettre aussi à le mettre en cinq ans le
5 ou g5 c'est à dire il peut il peut
jouer cavalier e 2 avait l'idée
cavaliers c1 puis cavaliers detroit
qu'un lycéen qualité 3 puis cavaliers 5
mais là il faudrait changer par le
carrier 17
oui ils se feraient chargé mais il
resterait avec la domination absolue des
cases noires puisqu'il ya plus de fou
noir chez les il ya plus de fous de
casement duché les noirs ou des noirs
chez les noirs et ensuite pour la finale
une fois le cavalier disparu peut-être
des périodes ont ils fait voilà il fait
cavalier de il est en train de faire le
petit parcours hippiques
une autre solution était de jouer
cavalier fin qu'un voyage deux cavaliers
f3 aussi cavale et j5 pour attac russie
est aussi un manoeuvre compliquée mais
finalement disons que tout ça c'est pour
améliorer les pièces qui sont mauvaises
le cavalier g3 n'avait plus de jeu
un puisque toutes les cases qu'il visait
directement était il a été contrôlé par
des pions contrôler ces cases ou d'ordre
contrôlés par des cinq ici par la 6e' si
celle ci lui donc il améliore cette
pièce en lui trouvant des cases qui sont
sur l'échiquier améliorer ce cavalier
car même à temps bien sûr le cavalier de
est plus fort que l'autre plan puisqu'il
a interdit le coutour c3 le contrôleur
ayant droits qui menaçait le permettront
qui attaque et le pont d'être emmenés
sur sa double double intérêt en fait
c'est aussi un coup défensif c'est aussi
un coup défensif c'est un coût qui
prépare cavaliers cm depuis cavaliers ni
cavaliers f4 puis cavalia 3 si
lecavalier 17 bouche alors on peut se
demander si des noix ont pas intérêt à
renault 1 voilà sur place et sage est en
train de dire à doubler mais pas mal
cette cool a évidemment il menaces enfin
ils menacent oui menace le noire menace
les charges des dames et donc le gain du
pur f6 et le gain du pion à s'il est
d'amasser change c'est idem s'échange
bon il faudra ensuite jouer des coups
passif pour défendre ce pion f6
attention c'est pas facile donc je pense
que laurent on va garder les dames
lorsqu'il va jouer dans bf3 frappé c'est
pas la première fois que l'on en fait
signer joue face à un fort joueur
régional dans ce grand prix puisqu'il
avait joué face à xavier beudaert en
ouais et qu' il a eu de grosses
difficultés puisque et sur dame f3 il
faut regarder le coup sec parce que en
cas de des princes 5
il y aurait le vis-à-vis fulham est donc
peut-être des coupes comme des quatre un
jour ou l'autre
or pour l'instant qu'il a vis-à-vis fort
en fout étroit avec le roi 7
mais il faudra it 100g vous l'auront à
8,2 pas choisi la maison qui avait pour
effet les charges des dames parce que il
considère qu'il a un avantage statique
armée bien protégé pions oui il est
obligé de le protéger une fois les deux
chargés d'âme fait l'équipe en f6 ont
réfléchi à tout de suite aux renault a
augmenté la pression sur m 6 de la part
des nord il pourrait le faire avec une
manoeuvre longue
maintenant je pense que laurent sait
qu'il a une paire de faux c'est sa
finale elle est là
elle est présente c'est vrai père dont
il va peut-être commencer organiser les
ruptures sur les droits c'est-à-dire f4
g4 se mettre au service de sa paire de
fou alors qu'à laisser si je vous ai
fait remarquer qu il amer oui ils
abandonnent l'idée de pression sur sur
b3 parce qu'il voit qu'il peut pas
encore dans les ces pièces pour attaquer
b3 donc il essaie de pourquoi j'avais
jamais notre blanc peut-être possible
pour lui c'était de jouer le coup par
exemple poussé 6 et ensuite cavalier 17
voiliers des six même si c'est embêtant
et kallio 8 pour faire pression sur sur
m6 mais c'était compliqué ses complices
avaient l'air très très bon un peu lent
aussi là il faudrait qu'il ya le dernier
coup la deux
de laurent oui il veut solide et il veut
jouer j'ai quatre oui de manière à
prendre avait le pion aux élèves de
manière à prendre mais le pion f et
avoir un candidat pour un pied en quart
d'heure explique nour nom lors du quart
d'heure puis un candidat c'est quand on
a deux pieds en voisin et que l'un d'eux
alain van sant deviendra qui ont passé
un peu passé ça veut dire comme c'est un
pion qui peut aller à dame un pion gants
pour aller à dame
parce que l'idée c'est que quand on a
repris du pur regarder du g4 pierre
comprend qu'ils ont eu pendant et après
ce pion ici contrôle académique on peut
jouer davantage calarasi saint caprais
de prison reprend est en amélioration
qui à l'aide à la voie ouverte et ça
c'est toujours embêtant
voilà surtout dans ce type de position
un peu coincé ici oui pas facile d'aller
chercher grèce et où les fous sens très
puissant est intéressante pour
accompagner les pions le dernier coup j
en haïti ce qu'ils avancent ça fait une
erreur ce coup là renault parce que dans
que la marque veut absolument de casser
la paire de foudre ils échangent veulent
changer c'est bien pour me les chansons
du fou il échange d'une part son mauvais
fou et d'autres peurs il enlève un et de
food et des blancs un univers musical et
les blancs pouvaient difficilement s'y
soustraire sinon le fou le case blanche
à 6 c'est le full le fou noir de cate
blanchet encore et travailler sur
l'échiquier est là maintenant il avait
anticipé ça parce que c'est un homme
être évidemment et il prépare il a
préparé son attaque la marque parce que
c'est parce que le pion le pion va être
difficile à défendre maintenant menace
pions proches 598 cavalier va gagner ce
pion tue toutes les filles on peut jouer
cavalier 4 ça qu'il faut prendre on
reprend les pions f est évident à onna
le candidat alors bien sûr les noirs ne
sont pas dépourvu d'atouts puisqu'ils
ont aussi un candidat centrale ils ont
depuis un centre au lait pourrait
pousser autant dd 5
bien sûr ils peuvent lire d'ailleurs
honoré la variante faire de 5
surtout on prend le cinq cavaliers prend
oui mais il ya la légende s inquiète
rennes et surtout reprendre des 5 ayem
qui achètent ici comme un ipod
fourchette
ah oui fourchette sur le four sur le fou
est défendue par le cai le fou est
défendue par le fonds par la caisse
parce qu'après le publiciste semblerait
selon le pion qui le cavalier c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué mais mais il
ya déjà des ya des techniques là donc
les joueurs calcul évidemment on va pas
rentrer là dedans mais donc il faut
calculer sa dérive est possible
j'étais de rupture de rupture au centre
pas parce qu'il s'est toujours très
intéressant d'observer dans le jeu de
son adversaire une pièce en l'air or là
on a le fou j'essaie qui est en l'air et
on s'aperçoit qu'il peut y avoir une
combinaison sur ce fond en l'air à base
de 5 e puis on prend cavaliers prendre
les cavaliers f3 que les freins
fourchette fourchette qui a taclé le fou
enfin alors c'est quoi la fourche et
d'avoir appelé pour ceux qui ne
bronchait fonctionne le cavalier attaque
à la fois le roi et le voilà une
fourchette c'est comme kaï-chek faut
parer les chèques et une fois qu'on a
paré l'échec
on prend le fou donc c'est comme une
fourchette à dos dans voilà on attaque
de vous faites à 2 dans deux pièces bon
voilà d'employés d'apple a fait tout ce
thème et est en route mais il peut quand
même prendre des cinq ans mais dans une
médiation est ce que c'est et noir
finalement ne jouais pas d'aiguillé
après ses voeux et le pian b3 et fragile
aussi le pion ce pion et fragiles et
ceux qui on tombe et bien le pion b4
était un candidat aussi qu'un candidat
ses missions passées oui là je pense
qu'il va jouer cavalier des quatre qui
est le cookie partout pour moi j'ai deux
jours wager willem il interdit l'entrée
mais ils empêchent la f3 le problème
c'est qu'il permet tour non il ne permet
pas tous ses droits c'est un il ya
toujours cavalier city qui veille au
grain tous ces trois ça c'est un
sacrifice de qualité qui peut avoir son
intérêt parce qu'on a deux pions à celje
et les deux cavaliers dans les pionts
c'est c'est à regarder c'est à regarder
alors attention tous et que ce coup
intéressant il veut menacer des trois
bien sûr sur marc lui est quand même
dangereux très dangereux intentions
laurent frayssinet six minutes quand
même pour l'enraciner contre 3 minutes
30 on voit quand même que laurent
frayssinet aussi mais la pression autant
donc il a toujours ce candidat potentiel
sur le côté et le dernier coup de marc
lévesque est très intéressant
les d4 l'idée de d4 et de dire voilà
sans doute surtout reprend cavaler
prendre là ce qu'a fait laurent
donc c'est un sacrifice mais non contre
le plus
ces trois lycéens il va jouer pour ses
trois passes qui menacera tour prend b3
d'abord quoi tout de suite un jour avec
cabaye et faye le fruit voilà bien joué
mark hughes qui joue sa chance à fond et
sûr mais on a quand même très peur
évidemment le plomb et fils quand même
proche de la promotion qui fait de
sacrifier ici quand une grosse pression
ici de ce côté là mais c'était blanc il
a donné la c il a donné un pion pour
activer c'est bien c'est pour activer sa
tour pour rendre les pièces blanches
passive
si ce que lecavalier passif il défend le
pian b3 il peut pas bouger la menace la
menace est réelle
le fougueux noir le cavaly c5
vous nous voyez attaque des trois
attaques b3 et en france menace la
fourchette menace la fourchette attaque
la tour oui mais le fou les en fait les
pièces blanches sans passive à la main
le fou g5 est pas terrible
la part de mark hughes ex coût des
quatre très jolie sacrifices très belles
parties qui ont fait lundi terrell
compréhension des en difficulté ont
apprécié les jeux et de la position elle
c'est pas facile de jouer contre un
adversaire moins fort en fait ouais
on peut avoir tendance à se relâcher
alors faut être cas de laurent
frayssinet les profite du fait que le
plan réussisse est imprenable
alors est ce qu'on voudra président et
pourrait commencer à rien par exemple à
faire un peu confiance
ici je pense que là il est en train
d'activer s'en fout de cases noires
cavaliers detroit donc attaque le fou à
les noms du jeu nombre de jeux renault
moi je commence ça va être quand même
assez inquiet pour leur en fait signer
parce que les coûts cavale ssl va venir
avaient droit sans compter que après ici
ce cavalier détroit le pion m6 est
attaqué alors ils étaient obligés de
redescendre à 6 on a peur du coup
cavaliers c5
oui mais il a toujours ce candidat qui
va aller très vite alors voilà c'est le
problème ça valait le candidat va aller
très vite que laurent frayssinet va
laisser les et le pion b et noir sera
puissant aussi très chaud quand même sur
un puissant aussi très riche où les deux
joueurs en des belles possibilités pas
se tromper mais attention au temps aussi
la pression on a quand même du côté
laurent frayssinet ça joue énormément
partie rapide oui oui on peut dire que
là quasiment les usa attention si
parquet m'a lancé voilà s'il arrive en
dessous d'une minute il aura quasiment
le désavantage d'un pion entier d'autant
que c'est du chaos
donc il faut absolument que marc lui est
que commence à activer le rythme et
c'est là que laurent frayssinet va
peut-être la somme et avec un coup
gagnant voilà baisser le coût qui a
laissé très jolie puisque sur h4 run ou
tout simplement le pion g4 est ample et
disparaît un tour de pression sur le
cavalier ou 5 que veut faire que veut
faire ici
laurent frayssinet rixe au couteau deux
voies la robe et s'il va très bien il
joue très très bien a marqué avec 1 7
mais bien sûr je vais très bien ce match
voilà fou d'edouard oui voilà donc il
saleh il joue food et 2 donc la tour va
enfin partir et se tue en b3 va pouvoir
respirer enfin peut-être pas prévu ce
tout simplement se couche au sacrifice
sacrifice de mark hughes oui puis il va
poser des problèmes il pose des
problèmes maker mais attention là il
donne une qualité
il donne une qualité mais pour [ __ ]
ensuite coller ces deux
faut pas oublier qu'il a un roi très
actif maintenant et que les pions en
baissant très faible le pl et les pions
dallel dame le pion b le pion à 4 donc
quand il ne peut refuser ça que ce
sacrifice c'est la question n'y a pas
intérêt
s'il refuse c'est ouais mais s'il prend
il ya beaucoup de jeu mais kable c2 a
l'air de tenir cavaliers ces deux on
peut le prendre direct non pour prendre
cavaliers comprend donc il a aussi dit
la créature a mis d'accord avec eux tu
comprends maintenant vers les six là il
a accepté mais n'ont qu'à vous laisser 2
et voilà que les autres cavaliers c'est
de bloquer le carlit bloc
oh la la il a donné la toile oui mais
obligé et pourquoi parce qu'elle a été
attaquée par le cavalier en d3 il fit
donc ici j'ai pas compris ce qui s'est
passé sinon ils attaquaient la tour
c'est pour ça qu'il a il a proposé des
changes donc ici il ya deux candidats
trois des cinq de candidats blancs sur
les droits sur les ailes dame
il ya deux candidats voilà c'est ça très
vite sa roue et b4 oui on peut jouer
avec le coeur à 4 passes et des jouets
dernier coup là le goudron au centre
c'est pas évident joué comme un signe
final très technique la très technique
qui ont une belle partie de marc leguay
qui tient la dragée haute à laurent
facilement cette première partie ça va
peut-être se jouer là ça va se jouer
autant ça se joue autant parce que ça en
trois minutes contre une minute 20 il ya
du mal au final le cavalier sansan
difficile un difficile à jouer parce
qu'il faut vraiment anticiper les jours
y de cavaliers pour accéder à certaines
cases
ah oui cavaliers 17 bien jouer qu'avec
des serrures de marquion et vie mais il
va perdre le pion cette affaire
d'options ces trois bières des droits
car les problèmes 6-3 prend on apprend à
mailhac cheikh suivi de cavaliers deux
attaques
ouais ouais c'est quand même si c'est
pas fini c'est pas facile c'est pas fini
c'était très bien joué de la part de
mark hughes est là qui cette position je
crois aboutir et objectivement bien
faire nul à une nulle mais il ya le
temps il ya la terminant nul oui il ya
le temps mais sur une minute 12 ça va
être difficile y est arrivé en forme et
cavaliers oui il veut enfermer le
cavalier peut-être cavaliers mais
lecavalier
les cavaliers à huy où là il veut venir
il veut venir gagner le pion à les
prendre le pur mais un simple cavaliers
voilà oui il va prendre plus anciens
comme l'alsace est bon alors là parce
que c'est perdu
je pense qu'il ya deux pions passé lié
il ya deux purs pas s'il y est donc
manoeuvre de laurent fasciné calais et
reste que 50 secondes à part qu à cassis
est le problème le problème c'est que la
partie comme une barque le bec mais mais
mais technicolor a fasciné très bienvenu
parce que marc a joué un coût faible de
cavaliers en classe et sexy trop de
wallace en jouant cavalier au cices
ils se mettaient à 4 tendue du pion g4
est donc difficile à aller capter le
plancher c'est trop dur
maintenant il est en train d'essayer de
se réorganiser pour aller capter le pion
g4 qui a validé cette c4 mais la verdure
à leroy va défendre ça va être trop dure
voilà il défend maintenant détaillé et
il va pousser ses pions là il va jouer à
5 celui de l'aller à qui on voit ça y
est c'est parti ça va aller très bien
qu'il faut croire la b4 c'est pas
possible arrêter ça les deux parents ça
va être perdu pour marquer que très bien
très bonne technique vous rend fait
signer les bonnes techniques vers la
finale et pression autant ils auraient
tous ceux dont des remarques le mec qu'a
pas réussi c'est trop difficile de jouer
à cette cadence et le parti est très
belle partie quand même
marc lübeck donc ça sera la première
victoire en parties semi-rapides
aujourd'hui puisqu'on a eu deux nuls
dans le premier match
oui là c'est fini le cavaliere est voilà
minutes 50 elle a largement le temps de
mater laurent fonctionner vie seconde il
va perdre autant marqué avec
malheureusement il n'aura pas le temps
de jouer il a pris trop de temps
le cavaliere est il n'a pas réussi à
accélérer la cadence voilà c'est fini à
6 kouassi sous le coup même b5 voilà
assis sur la selle c'est terminé ça y
est c'est fini les pions ses pions et a
revu le sait le cavalier de l'échiquier
c'est terminé voilà bordeaux et belle
partie très très belle partie de leur a
fait signer belle résistance de l'équité
la première quelques minutes juste ne
trois minutes de pause à peine avant de
devoir nous sommes la deuxième manche de
ce match
[Musique]
on